sie werden ja auch ein bisschen als
papier terroristen bezeichnet einige
wohl einfacher sprache ich zahle keine
steuern so lange 90 abgaben für den
krieg aniston geschichtsrevisionisten
die rechtsextremisten die
können wir unsere lage erfasst haben
werden wir wissen was zu tun ist
ihr chef bin ich und jetzt bittet die
menschen die die bundesrepublik für eine
firma halten die glauben es hätte nie
einen friedensvertrag gegeben keine
steuern bezahlen und lieber einen
eigenen fantasie stadt kosten
dem schöpfer allen seins seiner orden
und den menschen zu dienen reichs bürger
galten allenfalls als spinner
bis die situation im herbst 2016
eskalierte
zunächst bei der zwangsräumung durch das
sek bei adrian ursache
und nur zwei monate später bei der
ermordung eines polizisten durch
wolfgang plan es gab eine explosion ins
spiel
richtige explosion es kommt es überhaupt
nicht vorstellen der ganze boden hat
gibt leute die ganze tür die ganze
behälter mit allem drum und dran die hat
sich
[Musik]
die
explosion war schwarz vertrauen
mittlerweile ist und reichs bürger nicht
mehr nur spinner sondern eine gefahren
nicht die
deutschen haben
die staats verweigerer von staatenlos
punkt info sind mit ihrer dauer
mahnwache vor dem reichstag ein
gewohnter anblick in berlin mein erster
anlaufpunkt bei der suche nach der
reichs bürger szene hallo
dokumentation über wird und
selbstverwaltung kein interesse was sie
da reingehen bei den fragen weil die
oder beim bundesverwaltungsamt sind sie
gut aufgehoben
auch keine steuer für tierversuche oder
für irgendwelche jäger oder
tierquälereien oder sie bezahlt also
kein stunden ich zahle keine steuern so
lange 90 prozent unserer abgaben für den
krieg es muss schluss sein mit dem
verschlüsselungs wir wollen kein geld
wir brauchen gar keine gelder brauchen
liebe untereinander auf marktverhalten
lage diesen nazis.de
das was reichs bürger auszeichnet ist
ein gewisses
querulatorische und manchmal auch im
verbalen aggressives verhalten gegenüber
den sachbearbeitern sachbearbeiterinnen
in den kommunalen verwaltung eine
diskussion mit reichs bürgern ist in der
regel nicht möglich weil sie
versuchen ihre auffassungen zu
transportieren und sind für
gegenargumente überhaupt nicht
aufgeschlossen
guten morgen welche schiedsgericht ist
für sie zuständig
[Musik]
natürlich das muss ja sie sind ja nicht
grundrecht berechtigt
[Musik]
ich muss an dieses gespräch mit ihm
führen und zu habe ich ein schreiben von
ihm bekommen einen pfändungsbeschluss
soll das hier sein ja da haben sie
angekreuzt sie beziehen sich auf die
justiz beitreibung ordnung in verbindung
mit der cpu
ja dann noch was wir jetzt mal darauf
aufmerksam dass die justiz beitreibung
zuordnung von 1937 ist dass es war sie
gesetzt das gesetz ist verboten laut dem
geltenden besatzungs recht schief
[Musik]
ich brauche einen konter aus
und zwar möchte ich ein gewerbe bei
ihnen eröffnen das ist vermutlich
ein gerichtshof zum beispiel
habe ich schon gemacht es gibt kein
rechtsanwalt ist kein rechtsanwalt der
überhaupt nicht vertreten kann
ja wenn sie das nicht lassen nein sie
werden das nicht
sie werden ja auch ein bisschen als
papier terroristen bezeichnet das heißt
da legt man schon mal gerne wunder
zeiten aufs wachstum schickt jahres
gericht durchgesetzt hat sich der
begriff reichs bürger als
sammelbezeichnung vor allem wegen den
vertretern die an die alten grenzen des
deutschen reiches glauben gerecht wird
dieser begriff nicht allen in der szene
dafür sind die ideologien zu vielfältig
und die einzelnen akteure zu verstricken
was sie eint ist die fixiertheit auf
angebliche und veraltete gesetze
meines erachtens spielen die sich zu
einer art jurist auf meinen das gesetz
besser zu verstehen als diejenigen die
gerade mit dem geltenden gesetz
operieren und wollen darlegen dass
gesetze entweder nicht mehr gelten weil
sie alt sind ausgelaufen sind oder
erfinden neue gesetze hinzu und wollen
dann darlegen dass diese nur in gesetze
die sich sie sich selbst ausgedacht
haben gelten
der kanadische richter die vogue trägt
ihr dafür 2012 den begriff pseudo legal
es gibt diesen begriff eigentlich schon
seit dem jahr 2012 da ist er geprägt
worden in einem berühmten
gerichtsverfahren meets gegen nazis das
und da wollte ein raichs bürger in
amerika nicht anerkennen dass er
verurteilt worden ist in einem
scheidungsverfahren und er hat dann
alles geleugnet was der richter aus
geurteilt hat war sogar der meinung er
geht als freier mann aus dem
gerichtsverfahren aber der richter hat
das nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und hat
auf
185 seiten
dezidiert
dargelegt warum all das was dieser
mensch vorgebracht hat in dem prozess
nicht auf waren gesetzen beruht pseudo
legale aktivisten sind eine weltweite
bewegung die in deutschland bislang nur
unter dem begriff reichs bürger
aufgefallen sind der verfassungsschutz
schätzt die gesamtzahl der in
deutschland aktiven reichs bürger auf
etwa 18.000 kreisbürger szene ist
eigentlich eine sehr uneinheitliche wie
man so manchmal sagt er der rückgänge
szene einige einfache steuer sprachen
geld sparen sind mitläufer es gibt aber
auch einige die wir schon früher
beobachtet haben verfassungsschützer die
geschichtsrevisionisten die
rechtsextremisten die antisemit und dann
gibt es auch noch einen kleinen kreis
von profiteuren
gehören manager nennen wir die partie
verdienen sich eine goldene nase
da gibt es rechts und
seminar
für viel geld und eben auch diese
merkwürdigen fantasie ausweise
ich nehme an einem seminar von peter
fitzek alias peter der erste teil wer in
das königreich deutschland aufgenommen
werden will muss erst mal bezahlen knapp
100 euro kostet ein seminar
auch wenn peter fitzek auf eigene
fantasie werbung setzt euros von seiner
gefolgschaft nimmt er immer gern an
[Musik]
witzig ist nicht nur oberster souverän
sondern auch geschäftsmann und lässt
sich die seminargebühr auf ein
polnisches konto überweisen um so der
deutschen steuer zu entgehen
ich will mir das seminar mit versteckter
kamera bevor ich ihn im interview zu
seinen theorien befrage
[Musik]
der anfang war er nicht ganz gut fand
ich erst ist die vorgehensweise ohne
mich zu fragen beispielsweise das daheim
aufzunehmen und dennoch im prinzip sich
da auch als was anderes darzustellen und
vorzustellen
ich weiß nicht
lte soll jetzt ein
internationales
habe ich auch schon seit 2005
steht
nahezu jeder in der szene scheint seinen
eigenen ausweis herzustellen von
deutschen reichs pässen bis zu
esoterisch religiösen pseudo dokumenten
innenstadt bei hildesheim hat einer der
bekanntesten dokumenten bastler der
szene seinen sitz norbert tiedtke ist
selbst ernannter reichskanzler der
exilregierung deutsches reich seine
wohnung dient als sogenannte
reichskanzlei
hier weht der muff der deutschen
vergangenheit durch das haus
das ist der person
überall auf der ganzen welt
den krieg nur ein deutscher oder eine
deutsche frau aber da schaut euch mal
unbedingt haben damit sie dann auch wenn
hier was damit ganz anderes passiert
ruhe verheißen ich benutze diese ideen
die also diese ausweisdokumente zum
beispiel um im internationalen
reiseverkehr von a nach b zu kommen und
in diesem benutzer oder diesem benutzer
ist nicht völlig egal und was ist ein
internationaler presseausweis das ist
wie die presseagentur wie barrieren
wird genauso peter der erste kredit von
deutschland geschrieben wir sind seit
reisepass dass deutschland hier will ich
jetzt mal bereisen oder es gibt
mittlerweile
gerichtsurteile beispielsweise wo man
das so sieht zum beispiel und da haben
wir mal ein beispiel besteht hier ganz
hinaus landgericht dessau roßlau
stiftung königreich deutschland
vertreten durch den treuhänder menschen
ressourcen jährige aus dem hause witzig
und peter fitzek nur noch ein klar man
zum beispiel wo ich einfach mehr gut
dass ich es keine ausnahmefälle mir das
ist ganz normal das ist ja ein
königreich deutschland peter erste würde
ich von deutschland steht das dritte
positive und jetzt mal eine bordkarte
von germanwings beispielsweise ruhig mal
aus mallorca zurück haben als könig von
deutschland ohne probleme gereist wenn
ich natürlich nur innerhalb europas
reise da muss ich oftmals gar kein
dokument vorzeigen wenn ich außerhalb
europas reise da muss ich schon
reisepass vorzeigen da kann es höchstens
passieren dass die mitarbeiter der
fluggesellschaft nicht ordentlich
hinschauen es ist schon möglich dass man
unter einem künstlernamen reicht und
wenn man könig peter der erste als
künstlernamen annehmen würde dann könnte
er darunter sicherlich reisen mit
einiges das gesamte dokument gefälscht
ist dann müssen die mitarbeiter der
fluggesellschaft schon genau hinschauen
und eigentlich auch checken dass das
kein korrekter reisepass ist das ist
hier im zum glück nur zweimal passiert
und 2015 ist er dann ja auch aufgeflogen
die bundespolizei hat ihnen damit nicht
reisen lassen
der führerschein
dass wir das begehrteste was die bullen
unterwegs stehen wollen
stunden lang befragen sowie der job tun
übrigens hat norbert scheed ganz anders
als er behauptet sehr wohl einen ganz
normalen führerschein
deutsches reich
dann den abwasch
das ist also kein bullen oder ähnliches
gibt was hier rum läuft
was mir etwas zu sagen hat steht dann
immer bla bla bla bla bla bla bla sollte
man unserem schluss sei bitte ihren
amtseid aber ich habe ihr chef bin ich
und jetzt bitte
gehen sie an die fürsten arbeit ist
nicht der einzige und nicht der erste
selbst ernannte reichskanzlei ist vom
ersten tage an bescheid ist immer die
original blühen
erster öffentlich auftretende reichs
bürger war wolfgang nebel der schon 1985
sein haus zur kommissarischen
reichsregierung erklärte
lassen wir den hübschen worten taten
folgen
damit dir selber alle auch tatsächlich
begreifen
wer wir
staatsbürger des reichs
verfassungsrechten staates deutsches
recht sind ebels thesen hat einen großen
einfluss auf andere staaten zum beispiel
auf horst mahler und sein deutsches
kolleg maler ist bekannt als
gründungsmitglied der raf wechselte aber
später in die extreme rechte und wurde
mitglied der npd mit seinem deutschen
kollegen veröffentlichte er eine fiktive
verfassung für das von ihm angestrebte
vierte reich und erst wenn wir unsere
lage erfasst haben werden wir wissen was
zu tun ist und was wir tun können
und wenn wir es tun können tun
müssen um als volk zu überleben aber es
ist zu wenig
sondern um als deutsches reich wieder
handlungsfähig zu werden
um den geist der uns ausmacht den
deutschen volks geist
als eine macht in der welt als eine
geistige macht in der welt wieder zur
wirkung zu bringen
die klassischen rechtsextrem mit mahler
und anderen früheren kommissarischen
reichsregierung bestimmten die
anfangszeit der szene heute ist sie
vielfältiger kryptischer eine melange
aus verschwörungstheorien rechter
esoterik und antisemitismus
du du hast schaffst du bist ein mensch
und als mensch dass keiner sich zwischen
dich und den schöpfer stellen und ich
bin absolut nicht religiös ist nun mal
die schöpfungen die das ganze erstellt
hat
und weil das sich dem weiß dass man sich
nicht einfach den menschen losgehen kann
und sagen so geht geld gibt das gebiss
haben sie eine person erschaffen oder
mehrere personen ein gängiges motiv
unter den starts leugnern ist die
unterscheidung zwischen mensch und
person wobei die person als symbol für
die versklavung durch den staat steht
tatsächlich unterscheiden wir juristen
zwischen personen und menschen
bei den personen gibt es quasi zwei
arten von personen natürliche personen
das sind die menschen und juristische
personen das sind vor allen dingen
vereine unternehmen wie gmbhs
aktiengesellschaften viele reichs bürger
unterscheiden auch zwischen personen und
mensch aber anders als juristen
unterscheiden sie danach das personen
ihrer meinung nach so was wie sklaven
sind menschen die freien menschen sind
deswegen würden sie auch niemals mit dem
vornamen und dem nachnamen
unterschreiben sich als mensch kenntlich
zu machen werden allerhand absurditäten
erfunden mal schreibt sich der name mit
doppelpunkt mal verbindet man seinen
namen mit einem einen nachweis
ein mensch auto graviert und eine person
einen menschen fingerabdruck das ist
dann das siegel
um zu verstehen wo diese theorien her
kommen müssen wir den sprung über den
atlantik machen
die usa waren in den 50er und 60er
jahren bestimmt vom widerstand gegen den
zentralstaat durch rechte organisationen
und steuer protestler daraus gründete
sich ende der 60er jahre die
rechtsextreme bewegung der position ii
tus eine regierungsfeindliche bewaffnete
miliz die sich auf die weiße
überlegenheit beruft ihr vordenker der
antisemitische priester william potter
geld formulierte die ersten theorien
eines ungesetzlichen staates
diese verfassungs auslegung wurde später
vom sovereigns sieht es in movement
übernommen militante regierungsgegner
und verschwörungstheoretiker gegen die
angebliche tyrannei der regierung
[Musik]
eine untergruppierung der souveränen
bürger die primondo land bilden das
direkte vorbild der deutschen
staatsmänner
sie entwickelten die theorien die das
normale gesetz ablehnen und sich auf das
naturrecht berufen ich glaube sie
berufen sich vor allem auf diese systeme
weil
sowohl das naturrecht also auch das sehr
recht als auch das handelsrecht viel
gewohnheitsrecht enthalten und
gewohnheitsrecht es eben nicht
geschrieben ist recht es wird zwar
angewandt von den gerichten aber es ist
eben nicht geschrieben und das tolle
beim gewohnheitsrecht ist man kann das
schön irgendwelche gewohnheiten noch
hinzu dichten die zwar von den gerichten
so nicht akzeptiert werden aber wo es
auch gar nicht so einfach ist
nachzuprüfen ob das wirklich jetzt eine
gewohnheit im sehr echt ist oder nicht
die freeman sorgten dafür dass die ideen
im mainstream ankam auch in deutschland
es war die dauer mahnwache vor dem
reichstag bei der xavier naidoo 2014
auftrat und die anlaufstelle für starts
leugner aller art ist was sie alle eint
der hass auf die medien selber sind ja
nur bei auftrag wissen jetzt ist es
interview machen irgendwie war es
versuchen reinzuholen davids den reichs
bürger artikel vielleicht gebastelt
kriegen vielleicht auch nicht
aufgeklärten bremse doch endlich die
deutschland frage bringen sie dort das
deutsche reich die bundesrepublik nicht
erfolge ist das deutsche reich
handlungsunfähig ist dass wir 70 jahre
fremd besitzt und verwaltet werden durch
betreuten sind dringen sehen warten
bitte bringen sie das bitte in der bild
danke
wir haben unser bekenntnis realitäts
aktivierung gelöbnis über alte sagen wir
es darum diese zu tragen antisemitismus
ist die grundlage für die reichsbahn
bewegung mit welchen werkzeugen
die marionetten die auf der bühne der
geschichte stehen bekannte damit genau
das 80 und hausanschlüssen das bringt
aus rechten gedankengut entsteht immer
gewalt